[Laughter]
hey sorry about that vampire of the
Masquerade Justice is a brand new
stealth game where you get to become an
actual vampire tourists go home well why
so many bottles and they're all full
what are you what what is wrong with you
people this is perfectly good wine oh
man look at me
go oh I'm so strong there's no way I can
actually do this in real life the beauty
of video games ladies and gentlemen hey
be quiet everybody be very quiet what a
what a terrible place for a security
guard to stand um super convenient for
me but like in general let's
go spanked you you got spanked
absolutely spanked TF
up go first
one the noise it made this is
legitimately amazing how do I just stay
as a vampire Forever at this point
vampire the Masquerade Justice is
available now on the meta Quest store
check it out